which gm would you want to be for the
2020 draft peter gets the trivia
question if he gets it right he gets the
first pick in the draft the dolphins
have three first-round picks this year
the last time they used multiple picks
in the first round was 1992.
who was their first pick
in 1992
miami dolphins multiple first-rounders
peter king was covering the nfl he
should know this folks because he knows
everything i'm just trying to increase
the pressure who was their first pick in
1992
oh let me give you a hint let's hear
your clue let me give you here's the
hint he still
is part of the national football league
today
uh
he's part of the league office clue he's
part of the league office oh troy
vincent
uh that was too easy all right i'll give
it to you anyway i'm in a good mood
today
no don't give it to me because you you
gave it you gave it away you gave it
away you take the first pick
that's true who else in the league
office was even drafted yeah what now
river on right yeah now now that john
runyon's gone
yeah is he gone i don't know is he
i think he's still there i'm not anyway
no you take it you take it
all right um you know i i thought about
this and i considered a bunch of
different names and
i think this is as simple as it can
possibly be i want to be brett veach
because i have patrick mahomes right let
me i i got the ring i got my homes i'm
the guy who found my home so nobody's
going to second guess me with anything i
can do i could draft troy vincent with
pick number 32 and no one's going to
call me into the principal's office
because i'm the guy who found patrick
mahomes i got the ring i got 20 of 22
starters coming back i am drafting for
luxury all the other schlubs are
drafting for need i'm just drafting
because i have the pick i may as well
use it on somebody so let me be bret
veach in this draft peter
as much as there's going to be
pressure ratcheted up on me because i am
the general manager under the biggest
spotlight in all of the nfl
i would want to be chris greer and and
look mike we can talk about whatever you
want to talk about would it be the right
pick to take tua
would it be the right pick to take
herbert are you afraid of to a long term
because of his health we all get that
he's going to have to take a calculated
risk with this pick without any question
so
the reason that i want to be chris greer
is not because he's either going to be a
genius and the executive of the year in
two years for doing this or he's going
to be the village idiot and he's going
to get fired
the reason i want to be chris greer
i'm going to give you let's assume that
he uses the fifth pick in this draft on
his quarterback somehow okay whether he
has to move up a little bit or whatever
but that fifth pick is going to be his
quarterback i'm gonna give you four
other numbers right now mike
and those four other numbers are 18 26
39 and 56.
those are the draft choices that chris
greer has
in a draft
that he needs to upgrade his roster at
some of the positions
that are smack dab
right down the middle in the sweet spot
of this draft
he could easily still get a very good
tackle in this draft with one of those
picks he can bolster his wide receiver
core to go along with devonte parker uh
you know at the other spot
he can also get another really good
front seven player that they need and so
to me
i look at this and obviously he can get
a corner uh you know to to basically
also bolster that secondary and so to me
i look at this and i say
i understand there's all that pressure
on you up there getting your quarterback
but
i'm fine because i got four more picks
in the top 60.
my only concern about being chris greer
in this draft is the inability to work
up the draft the way that you would in
any other year like it's always good to
have three first round picks this year
it's more precarious because you don't
have the private workouts you didn't
have the facility visits brandon bean
the bill's gm told me last week but
nobody else missed out either
i understand but you still but every
time you roll the dice it's more it's
more of a crap shoot it's already a crap
shoot you're shooting even more crap
this year i'd rather have three first
round picks in a year when i can do more
homework and have a better feel about
the guys i love and feel less like i'm
just throwing a dart in the dark that's
my only concern about being chris greer
one of the picks that he got this year
the 18th overall comes from the
pittsburgh steelers and i would want to
be kevin colbert in this draft because i
could look at my first round pick that
would have been number 18 and say i got
minka fitzpatrick and in this year with
all the uncertainty i've got a guy who's
going to be the cornerstone member of my
secondary like troy palamalu was for the
next 10 years and maybe longer because
it's clear fitzpatrick is and i remember
when they traded for fitzpatrick it was
one of those where we didn't know who
was going to trade for mika fitzpatrick
but when the steelers emerged it's kind
of like
damn it we should have known that that
was the perfect place for minka
fitzpatrick and he's been great for them
there was some talk of defensive player
of the year based upon his performance
last year that's my first round pick
i've already used it i'll watch minka
fitzpatrick highlights when that 18th
pick is on the clock and i'll say good
luck chris greer making use of that pick
when you haven't had a chance to get
ready for this draft the way you've
gotten ready for every other draft so
let me be kevin colbert also kevin
colbert pretty good at finding receivers
in the mid to late rounds of the draft
an incredible track record they need
receiver help
they haven't filled the void with
antonio brown and i know that colbert's
got the skills
to find the right guy in the right round
to help them lift that passing offense
to a higher level
well if james washington and or deontay
johnson come through the way
they hope i would agree with you but
that that 18th pick and again i love
minka fitzpatrick and i think
that is good value for that pick
but
they obviously have needs the steelers
do with a bunch of veteran players
getting older but but again i i can
agree with you on that one because i
like that trade for the steelers
so
my second guy is going to be john lynch
and this is the reason why
so
he knew that he couldn't pay all of the
defensive linemen that he had so he gets
rid of deforest buckner and now i
believe
at that higher pick
uh in number 13 overall he's going to
think of one of these really good
defensive tackles derek brown javon
kinnlaw one of those two guys could come
into san francisco and play right away
this is a super bowl team that is a very
young team there's not a lot of
positions where you can have somebody
come in at a manageable salary at one
quarter of them of the money uh that
deforest buckner is going to make and
i'm at a
you know at a manageable salary you have
him come in there and then
at number 31 you have the ability to
then take the best player available now
mike
everybody is saying the 49ers got to go
get a receiver
i don't agree okay and i'll tell you why
i don't agree because kyle shanahan can
make receivers out of what i call the
last hour trait receivers like debo
samuel i wouldn't be surprised if they
traded down at 31 because they don't
pick again until the fifth round after
number 31
to trade
and to to end up maybe around number 50
and still get a first-round caliber
receiver if that's what they want so to
me when i look at john lynch i see a guy
who's got a lot
of things in this draft that he can do
and they're all
good all right let's get through round
three quickly because we got to get to
break but i will go with jerry jones
just because i'd love to be jerry jones
for three days i'd love to live like
jerry jones for three days i'd love to
have no accountability right all these
other guys have to worry about getting
fired jerry jones has been asked the
question i remember the bob costas
interview 10 years ago would you have
fired yourself by now and he said i
probably would have but you know what i
can't i'm the owner of the team and you
could do the draft one day in your
mansion one day in your bus
one day on your yacht right and still
comply with the stay-at-home orders i
want to be jerry jones i don't know that
i can handle it more than three days i
don't know that that i've got the johnny
walker blue tolerance uh or that i ever
will but i would love to be jerry jones
for this draft just because i've seen
some of the clips some of the interviews
they've done with players and it just
would be great to be the gm of the
dallas cowboys and not have to worry
about getting fired no matter how badly
i screwed it up all right peter who you
got
i'm going to be far more boring i'd say
i want to be marty herney i want to be
the carolina panthers general manager
for two reasons number one
uh i can get a franchise cornerstone
player at number seven if i so choose i
can also trade that is going to be a
spot where teams are going to want that
pick so if he wants to he can trade down
a little bit or he could get a
cornerstone tackle
that would be potentially a left tackle
for his team
for the next 10 years and not only do
you have 7 and 38 but you have matt rule
you know why matt rule is an advantage
and why three
baylor assistant coaches are an
advantage hey mike the most important
undrafted free agent period ever
ever
is this year
in the two hours after the seventh round
five to 600 players will reach agreement
on contracts who were not drafted and
the advantage of having matt rule and
his staff all of whom recruited college
football or high school football kids
heavily
is that now
those kids are coming in the draft he
knows them he knows their mothers he
knows who they are he knows them as
people so to me having matt rule on your
side an undrafted free agency this year
is like having
five extra sixth round picks because
that's the caliber of player you're
gonna get in the undrafted market this
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports